one piece of functionality that's still
missing from our conference central app
is that so far there's no way for users
to register to attend a conference
although we see the register button in
the UI it doesn't do us any good to
click it because we haven't implemented
the function that it calls you're going
to be adding that feature next the
process of registering for a conference
involves several separate tasks
including updating the users profile to
know which conferences they have
registered to attend as well as
decreasing the number of seats available
for the conference also what happens if
there's only one seat left for the
conference and several people try to
register for it at the same time who
gets it how do we handle those potential
conflicts we're going to use
transactions to ensure that all relevant
entities get updated or none of them do
and to make sure the only one person can
get the very last seat at a conference
we're going to use a property called
conferences to attend to keep track of
which conferences a user will attend and
this property is going to be on the
profile entity so in the profile class
you'll need to add some things you'll
add the conference keys to attend field
this property contains a list of the
keys for all the conference's that the
user has registered to attend and note
that it's a list of strings you're also
going to need most likely to fix the
import you'll also need to define the
getter method for this property to
return a copy of the list and rather
than a regular getter method what you'll
need instead is a method that takes a
conference key and adds it to the
existing list so we're going to call
that add to conference keys to attend
and this is how you'll define it you'll
add the new conference key to the
existing values you'll also need to add
a method to remove a value from
conference keys to attend in case the
user decides to unregister from a
conference so basically the unregister
from conference method simply removes a
conference key from the existing values
but it needs to check first that the
conference key is already in the
property and if not throw an invalid
conference key
exception I mean basically you can't
unregister from a conference that you
haven't actually registered for then in
the conference API class you're going to
need to write the method register for
conference you can start out by copying
the skeleton code for register for
conference from the lesson 4 folder and
copy it into the conference API class
here it is register for conference we
want this method to return true or false
to indicate whether the registration was
successful or not but endpoints
functions must return objects they can't
return simple data type object such as
string or long or boolean use a
classical wrapped boolean instead of
boolean as a return type of the method
so the file that contains the skeleton
for register for conference also
contains a full implementation of the
wrapped boolean class so here's a
wrapped boolean class it basically has a
couple of fields result and reason the
result is going to be the true or false
and the reason it's going to be the
reason for the result and typically
you'll set the reason if the result is
false we just have a constructor that
takes the result in the reason we have a
constructor that just takes a result and
then we have getters for the result and
the reason that same file also includes
a definition for the function get
conference which return to conference
given a string of its key this mess that
is used by the UI for the app to get the
details to show on the page where you
can register for a conference you won't
be using it in your transaction but
you'll need to have it if you want to
use a UI to register for a conference
and you're going to need to fix a couple
of the imports the named class comes
from Java Rex or inject and the not
found exception comes from the servitor
SPI dot response package so let's import
that and the gate conference is provided
fully implemented for you you should be
able to understand the code that it
implements so back to the code for
register for conference we need to
import couple more exceptions and
they're all in spi response so you're
going to be implementing this code so
what you're going to do is obviously
check
if the user is null and if it is throw
an unauthorized exception then you're
going to start a transaction and then
you're going to write the code to get
the conference key get the conference
entity and if there's no conference with
the given conference ID you're going to
instead of just throwing an exception
you're going to create a new wrapped
boolean that's false and you're going to
need to set the reason to explain why
it's false and you're going to get their
users profile you're going to check if
the user already registered to attend
this conference and if they did you're
going to need to create a new wrapped
boolean set it to false and explain why
you're also going to need to take
account of whether there's any seats
left and if not you're again going to
have to create a new wrapped boolean and
explain that there's no seats left then
if all the conditions are met and it's
okay for the user to register for the
conference go ahead and do the
registration so you need to add the
conference key to the users conference
keys to attend property you need to
decrease the number of seats available
you need to save the conference and the
profile entities and then you need to
return a wrapped boolean whose value is
true because this transaction requires a
wrapped boolean result and then if there
were reasons why it didn't succeed
you're going to need to turn around and
throw the appropriate exceptions and
then finally return the result so one
more thing to mention is that when you
do go ahead and book the seeds the
conference class already has a method
book seats that just decreases the
number of seats available in the
conference it's already implemented in
the conference class so you can go ahead
and look at that so all this code takes
place inside of a transaction so you're
going to need to know how to write the
code for a transaction in objectify